it's not a reach to say that fastx is
overflowing with colorful newcomers and
one actor who most people know from the
small screen is making a big impression
on audiences spoilers ahead for fast
acts as more and more Fast and Furious
fans rushed to movie theaters to
experience fast Stacks a lot is going to
be said about Jason momoa's head turning
performance as the franchise's most
dangerous villain yet Dante Reyes
rightly so he has been hailed as
delightfully deranged and gleefully
committed disrupting the usual trend of
brooding foes with a turn so earnestly
flamboyant that it borders on genius
and yet he's not the only fast newcomer
who deserves praise for what they bring
to the franchise during its final
moments the true star making performance
of fast ax ultimately winds up being
none other than Alan richson who plays
the film's secret villain ancient Ames
in his first scene on screen Richton is
tasked with going toe-to-toe with
oscar-winning actor and billion dollar
Blockbuster Superstar Brie Larson not
only that but he delivers a fourth wall
breaking monologue that could have
easily come across as weak lamp shading
but it's delivered with such Charming
conviction that it perfectly tease up
the rest of the film's ridiculous Antics
it violates the laws of God and gravity
they did it twice Rich then only gets
better from there as he slips into the
franchise's style like a tailored suit
it's exciting to see him shine in a roll
like this after proving himself as a
Bonafide Action Hero on the small screen
though Rich then gave memorable
performances in 2013's The Hunger Games
Catching Fire in 2014's Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles reboot fans really began
to take notice when he joined the cast
of the DC Universe series Titans from
2018 to 2021 he played the superhero
Hawk less than a year after his
departure from the series he began
leading a show of his own on Amazon
Prime playing the title character in The
well-received drama Reacher
[Applause]
from being the perfect straight man to
mamoa's Darkly comic criminal mastermind
Rich then proves in fast acts that he's
ready to take on major action roles in
the near future in each and every
performance he gives Rich sin is
consistently entertaining and if given
the right role the actor could easily
lead a story of his own after his
performance in fast acts it's hard not
to imagine Hollywood taking advantage of
Rich then's slick Charisma and Char for
richson joining the ever-expanding Fast
and Furious franchise was nothing short
of a dream come true Rich then said in
an interview this was one of the easiest
decisions in my career to be a part of
something that's been a part of my life
since I was a senior of high school I
grew up watching been in the Gang seeing
how the latest entry in Vin Diesel's
magnum opus ends on a giant Cliffhanger
it's all but likely that the past X
Trilogy will continue to expand upon
aims considering how unhinged Jason
momoa's villain is audiences can expect
tons of conflict between Dante and Ames
hopefully the sequel gives Rich sin a
more Central role now that the true
intentions of ancient Ames have been
revealed or perhaps the character could
have a change of heart the possibilities
are endless for richton's complex
character it's time to prepare for
what's coming you might want to buckle
up
[Music]